to wrap up 2016 we are counting down
some of the top whatever YouTube videos
of the year here's one that I think uh
many people will like particularly the
trolls here are the five videos that
triggered the largest number of
unsubscribes on YouTube and this is
funny because I've talked before but
I've so many people go into the comment
and they say that's it this video put me
over the top I'm now unsubscribing and
of course only a fraction of those
people actually do that let's count down
the top 5 videos that actually led the
largest number of people to unsubscribe
starting with number 5 the truth about
the regressive left some people did not
like this video some people were on the
left and some people were on the right
but there were people across the
political spectrum that did not like our
expose of the movement called the
regressive left not really a movement
that calls itself that but something we
call that the number four video that
triggered the most unsubscribe during
2016 a video called Donald Trump one
hundred percent correct a vote for green
party / Jill Stein helps me a lot of
people unsubscribing after I said Trump
was correct of course the election
results told us that I was indeed right
in agreeing with Donald Trump about that
you will notice Jill Stein uh has
multiple entries in this video the
number three video with the most number
of unsubscribes during 2016 embarrassing
Trump audio exposes him as totally
clueless a million views plus on that
video and a lot of trumpets did not like
what I had to say in that one the second
a highest unsubscribed video on YouTube
during 2016 Jill Stein second entry jill
stein off the charts pseudoscience
vaccines Wi-Fi radiation not one of the
most viewed videos but indeed one of the
videos that triggered the highest number
of unsubscribes forty percent of the top
five most unsubscribed videos of 2016
related to Jill Stein and finally the
number one video that triggered the most
unsubscribes across our channel of 2016
Reza aztlán it cannot be trusted of
course the counter is that it's one of
the videos that also triggered some of
the largest number of new subscribers
but there it is clearly the reza aslan
cannot be trusted video one of the most
controversial of the year any surprises
on that list packed for you know I have
to say actually number three is pretty
surprising i think the embarrassing
Trump audio elbows I don't see why
people that would be their last straw it
was pretty pretty straight ahead
critique of specific things that Donald
Trump had said it was fact-based it is a
little bit surprising part of it I think
is just a function of the number of
views it had because it did so well and
it was our most viewed new video from
2016 by the sheer math of it there were
bound to be people who saw it would
unsubscribe there they are the five
videos that triggered the most
unsubscribes in 2016 what videos will
they be in 2017 as my phone goes off
very bad form for me but hey it's the
end of the year